foreign
a telephone ringing in the night
a worried voice calling on the doctor
for help
in any language this spells trouble
nausea vomiting abdominal cramps and
diarrhea
trouble
and still more of the same
the number and severity of the symptoms
vary but they all fit a pattern
it looks as if the doctor has an
outbreak of acute gastroenteritis on his
hands
he won't get much rest this night
what could have caused the outbreak
suppose we go back several hours earlier
in the evening
and look in on a certain restaurant and
a dinner party which an executive is
giving his employees
recognize any of them
it's hard to believe these are the same
people isn't it
it's quite an event
they look healthy happy and well fed
what caused such a violent outbreak of
sickness only a little more than three
hours after the dinner
out of the total of 23 persons attending
this dinner
14 became ill with varying degrees of
nausea vomiting abdominal cramps and
diarrhea
it was a good dinner
they had ham fried cabbage
sweet potatoes
a very tasty salad
chocolate eclairs for dessert
plenty of good hot coffee
still something went wrong
let's see exactly what did happen to
cause so much suffering and misery
the water was ruled out as a
contaminating agent since it came from
the city water supply a pure one and no
similar outbreaks were reported
elsewhere in town at that time
the coffee was made fresh and served
piping hot
the only milk served was grade a
pasteurized and refrigerated
the bread was good and fresh
the salad and vegetables were ruled out
as probable suspects
due to the mixed incidents among the
guests of those who became ill
and those who did not
the meat was suspected because all of
the 14 people who became ill had eaten
ham
and the chocolate eclairs were
incriminated in the same way
everyone had eaten eclairs
laboratory tests confirmed the pastry as
the contaminating agent by revealing
colonies of staphylococci in the filling
this is staphylococcus aureus some
strains of which produce a toxin in the
food before ingestion
causing the most common type of all food
poisonings
now let's find out how this poison
developed in the pastry filling
from the restaurant manager it was
learned that although all the other
foods served were prepared in their
kitchen
the pastries had been ordered from a
bakery on the other side of town
they were delivered in the late
afternoon shortly before the dinner was
served
he remembered very distinctly that they
were promptly refrigerated
at the bakery we found the source of our
trouble
this baker didn't know it but he was the
carrier
for this superficial skin infection on
his forefinger contained colonies of
staphylococci which were transferred to
the pastry filling
we're not sure exactly when and how the
organisms were transferred from the
infection to the eclairs
but we're certain there was ample
opportunity
we investigated the bakery thoroughly
and the overall operation was excellent
the eclairs were made early in the
morning on the day of the dinner the
ingredients were good
the bakery and the baker were clean the
only breakdown in sanitary precautions
was this particular baker's infected
finger
a superficial skin infection
a little thing in a way but extremely
important to the people who became ill
the pastries were finished
and it was about an hour before the
delivery man picked them up for delivery
to the restaurant
uh-oh
motor trouble
the driver didn't know much about
engines so he decided to call a garage
for help
it was probably about this time that the
staphylococcus organisms from the
baker's infected finger began to grow in
the eclairs
and in growing they manufactured a
poison
the poison which made the people at the
party so
sick a driver found a telephone and
called a garage
then he waited
the mechanic didn't think the job would
take long
so he waited
and weighted
and all this time
the staphylococcus organisms were
growing and manufacturing poison in the
eclairs
finally he decided to call the bakery
and report his delay
he was told to go have his lunch and
wait a reasonable length of time
then when he returned to the garage
just had to wait
and wait in the uncomfortably hot garage
after several hours delay the repairs
were finally completed and the driver
started on his route
he had some other deliveries to make so
the organisms and the eclairs had still
more time to grow
the pastry filling was probably pretty
well contaminated by this time
it was late in the afternoon before the
pastries were delivered to the
restaurant
in fact it had been more than six hours
since the pastries were contaminated by
the baker's infected finger
by this time the eclairs were thoroughly
saturated with a poison from the
organisms
our story involved eclairs but it could
just as well have been meat milk milk
products other pastries
or any one of a long list of foods
with similar circumstances many foods
could have caused this outbreak
eliminate either the baker's infected
finger
or the long delay in the truck
and this outbreak of staphylococcus
intoxication
could not have occurred
there would have been no poison in the
food and the boss's dinner party would
have been nothing more than a pleasant
evening
everyone enjoyed a fine meal
and had a good time
you